we've got a great story with Vlad here
the pandemic has brought us together in
in more ways than one including a common
bond over the struggle with our hair
when Hair Salons closed Americans
resorted to cutting and coloring their
own hair and some efforts were more
successful than others in a CBS
primetime special airing tonight top
hair stylists and celebrities are
teaming up to offer tips and our Vlad GT
I spoke with the hosts of haircut
haircut night in America they're the
married actors Rebecca Romain and Jerry
O'Connell a good morning I guess they
assigned the bald correspondent to cover
the hair story so you can be completely
neutral on the subject exactly right
because let me tell you Jerry and
Rebecca both made it very clear that I
am NOT the target audience because of
this Tony to copal but I do learn this
very important lesson in trusting your
partner with your hair is risky business
we got to a point where literally
everyone needed a haircut or their roots
done not you Vlad clearly but we've all
gotten shaggy err and shaggy rose this
has done onward here I'm like Albert
Einstein and you know when you look at
yourself in the mirror like you lose
self-esteem married couple Rebecca
Romain and Jerry O'Connell may have
found a solution to those quarantine
fare mares the real life partners
partnered up for a one-of-a-kind
one-hour special haircut night in
America
we decided to do America a service we're
gonna bring on some of our favorite
celebrity
friends like kelly osbourne Jax painted
lindsey vonn and piqué Subban is this
big guy and lindsey Lowen this is gonna
be big when they came to you and said we
want you guys to do this what went
through your mind oh my gosh yeah well I
mean I guess I guess John Legend and
Chrissy Teigen I think someone saw one
of my posts and saw how gray I was
becoming it's crazy I'm full Anthony
Mason here and then full Scott Pelley
here with the help of top celeb stylists
the show weaves together the do's and
don'ts of DIY cuts color and style I
stopped breathing long with some
much-needed levy there are companies who
have been selling home coloring kits
that are doing business like gangbusters
because it's a real thing yes right
Rebecca cut and colored my hair and I
have never heard her so maniacal or
excited it's very exciting then when my
wife had clippers and was in back of my
hair I mean literally they were like
guttural like almost Ted Bundy esque
like sounds coming from her like those
dynamics that you're talking about the
dynamics of couples now getting into
each other's business which is the
business of hair which is so personal
that's a bold step in a relationship
it's a vulnerable position this
quarantine is really like the true test
of all relationships good night in
America where couples is like the
ultimate trust wall it's like a trust
fall on steroids from a five-story
building I have to say coloring my
wife's hair was the scariest day of my
life since our children were born
because Vlad I found this out too when I
was working with our expert of Rebecca
these are the most delicate hairs on our
head right there at the hairline and
therefore the easiest to burn off
when you're coloring them he said what's
the worst thing that could possibly
happen and so we had to explain to him
that these baby hairs get burned off
very easily and if the color stays on
for more than five minutes it'll all
burn off and then the stakes got raised
and Jerry got scared here we go we're
gonna go over here all right
we've been married for 13 years we
didn't truly become a couple until we
filmed haircut night in America Jerry
and Rebecca gave me that much-needed
laughter I needed this week haircut
night in America airs tonight at 8:00
7:00 central right here on CBS Tony I
know your wife Katie does your hair and
makeup these days but how much do you
really trust her I want to see on
Instagram I want to see Katie with those
clippers
you know I think all you need to know we
have a very strong and loving marriage
but we are not doing the trust fall with
cutting each other's hair that is not
gonna happen but okay all right are you
inspired to grow your hair out after
seeing people cut it at home you know
I'm still waiting for Anthony Mason to
give himself a buzz cut when that
happens Gail we've been waiting we've
been waiting yeah no wait you guys
turned it on me oh that was the other
way around it was the other way around
you have to grow your hair first and
then I'll do the buzz cut I'll get
myself a wig I'll take that